of course he's in business mode he knows
it's a race and uh okay they're off it's
all about the mouth skills now and it's
the scotch wow something that Wesley
knows a lot about you mentioned this on
the previous days Robert something
happened here what's going on with it
why he is annoyed about something maybe
he's annoyed at facing the scotch I mean
it's not something he gets to see every
day Wesley so has played this even in
classical events at the elite level so
it can't be a complete surprise but
Bishop D3 here that's not something
we're used to seeing oftentimes white
pushes the C Pawn to kick the Knight out
of the center but Bishop D3 I think this
is an Armageddon surprise yeah also
Hikaru launching the first surprise
blacks Knight coming into the center
maybe not the uh recommended antidote
normally black kind of creates a pin on
the e-file with the Queens a lot of
vocal tension there lots of theory of
course but both players trying to get
out of that theoretical battle now this
is far from anything we've seen uh
between these two before at least in
this tournament here's a bunch of
options he can just take the pawn as he
finally has done but I think he needs to
make these moves quickly that's what did
so well yesterday against Magnus it
didn't quite work out but he was playing
instantly in most turns and what hikar
Nakamura says usually is the best advice
play good moves quickly rather than the
perfect move slowly I think Wesley needs
to take that advice right now and okay
and that's what he was thinking about
David because this is an interesting
option he takes advantage of the fact
that Hikaru did not capture with the
bishop developing a piece or recapture
that bond with the queen and he is
attacking that D5 Knight black skin is
still in the center now one can be like
wait a second Hikaru can pin that Bishop
a very tempting option you move your
queen to E7 because White's King is also
in the center but that is when Wesley
says I don't care I'm going to go Castle
on the right side of the board and now
sure come on pick up my bishop and watch
out for your king in the center rookie
one pins and wins the queen Falls and
this is the idea that Wesley was looking
at he took his time to pick up that pawn
on D6 he took his time to go for the
most combative option with the Bishop to
E4 and we see the drawback with this
move Hikaru says I'm ready for a fight
doesn't care about that pawn in the
center develops his Bishop stops whites
King from getting to safety and this
position is not easy to figure out so a
car made a very interesting last move
but look at the Pawns in the center even
if you don't take it right away because
that does give black time to give the
king a check maybe bring the Rook
towards the center and go after White's
undeveloped Camp I feel like that's a
long-term problem and for her car it's
not going to be easy to solve and I
think that's exactly what Wesley needs
to keep pieces on the board keep the
problems there and he says let me just
grab the pawn right away no issues from
Wesley so's perspective it's going all
out and I love it of course the king is
still stuck in the center but not for
long uh David he can look at an idea of
going long castle castle on the other
side of the board but again that will
come with its own set of dangers yeah
he's uh not just looking at it I think
he's going to go for it Tanya and it's
more out of necessity than anything that
white king is never caught on King's
side the bishop cuts across the board
like a race of that queen and the Rook
have to get out of the path I think it's
just a little bit too slow it's a little
bit too slow indeed and uh okay he
speeds things up by attacking that White
Queen but the White Queen will happily
slide back the bishop will sit on this
nice Central post that we've highlighted
and White's King should still feel
relatively cozy comfortable on the queen
side but he can't react anymore he's a
pawn down the onus the burden is on him
and he's down more than five minutes now
of course which doesn't help at all okay
he's activating his Queen Hikaru nice
move there very logical and for at least
one move white cannot Castle on Queen
side because watch out for that A2 pawn
it will be hanging if white does decides
to get his King safety at this point so
currently kings are still in the center
black is threatening to Castle kingside
on the very next move and white Skin's
still struggling there so there is some
compensation as long as Hikaru can make
sure that the king doesn't get to safety
how much can you go wrong but still keep
it within manageable bounds
A3 stockfish the best move giving over
one point Advantage for white simply
because White's one Pawn up and Wesley
does eventually find the best move but
it did come at the cost of nearly five
minutes on the clock long long think and
now stockfish saying okay black has a
bunch of moves maybe the best is to push
black Central Pawn forward these guys
are so good they keep playing the best
move but uh is it enough it still thinks
stockfish the white has the advantage
who knows but Hikaru won't even look for
a mate he'll take the draw and get out
of here and that variation was scary
enough for Wesley so to retreat his
Knight but that's a really sad move to
play Not only have you put the Knight on
a terrible square but you've also got in
the way of your idea of Castle in
queenside get that pesky Bishop out of
C4 and the 93 protects C2 so you are
more likely to Castle queenside because
your Bishop on D4 protects the B2 Pawn
the Knight protects the C2 Pawn I feel
like Wesley has done some really nice
maneuvering here but a car reacting very
quickly as well playing for the attack
yeah playing for the attack so now these
black bishops are really getting their
money if they're really doing a good job
this is a nasty pin but if Wesley gets a
move or two to shuffle into the corner
he'll feel very very safe now and uh
okay Hikaru has that luxury it's only
one minute in it can he whip up an
attack can he get those black Rooks
active big questions here to answer for
both sides this one could go either way
on the board on the clock still
Advantage Wesley but not by much anymore
he does Shuffle into the corner really
not only defending his own the queen
side the long Castle but also eyeing
black skin on G7 gives Wesley the hope
to launch a king side attack and that's
what he's done and Hikaru taking this
opportunity to at least go in for an
opposite color Bishop position now if
pieces do end up getting traded it can
very well end in a draw as the Bishops
are not of the same color and those
positions are super famous for uh you
know even with extra material often just
being a draw but I'm expecting Wesley to
keep all the pieces on the board try and
create an attack on hikaru's King
because that's where the chances White's
Bishop cannot be challenged and that's
the key your queen jumps onto G5 you hit
that pawn on G7 you're already
threatening a mate in this position
Wesley looking for an attack yeah and
Hikaru looking very proud of himself
nodding his head there this last move a
very clever one I really like it just
putting his Pawn on F6 just neutralizing
any threats that the white Bishop can
create against the black king once those
threats have been neutralized Hikaru can
go about the job of just trading off the
Rooks trading off the Queens there we go
one set of Rooks have plotted from the
board if the Rooks and queens disappear
very likely to be a drawer but uh
opposite color Bishops only one good
thing in Wesley's back pocket he's up a
pawn and where is that pawn it currently
sits on B2 so at some point he's going
to pushed that pawn to B3 and spring
free a pass Pawn opposite colored Bishop
end games with just bishop and pawns
known for their tendency to be a draw
however if you can get an outside pass
Pawn you distract Black's pieces they
have to deal with that and then you can
focus on the other side of the board so
Wesley he is slightly better he is up a
pawn he's also still ahead but almost a
minute on the clock but this is where
her car was at his best he plays these
moves so fast he finds the strategies I
just think it's really truly difficult
even if the time had an hour on the
clock for each wow and now Hikaru hits
two bonds there was the h-bound hanging
and the g the only way to defend it is
what Wesley has played the queen jumps
further and now he's threatening
background threat so don't get greedy
with the queen Wesley if he starts
approaching the queen Side Pawn it can
very well end in disaster with a check
on the back rank he falls back first
eyeing the H5 Pawn instead as Robert
mentions the white porn stopped running
Hikaru says no can't allow the white
pawns to move and this is a really nice
Square for the black queen she's always
centralizing is good but she's eyeing up
those white pawns on the diagonal and uh
very very difficult for Wesley to
actually make progress he can move his
Bishop around but the white king not
entirely safe I feel like Hikaru is
playing extremely well right now yeah
and it's hard for Wesley to make any
Headway still a minute in it but uh okay
second time we've seen this position now
Wesley can't repeat he can't go for the
draw and it's feels like black spaces
are so active right now the queen and
the bishop and as long as they stay
alive Hikaru creates his chances and not
trading the Queens a great idea but I
also like what Wesley's doing he's
bringing the third piece into the game
it happens to be the king and we might
see the King march up the board all the
way starting to attack the ace the A4
Pawn Yeah and her car is terrified of a
potential King match by white he drops
the black queen here we go come on
Wesley so bring that King forward ask
those questions and if you're Hikaru
you're panicking right now because that
white king is going to support the
advance of the that white poor majority
on the queen side yeah and the queen
trade will not end in a draw we keep
talking about this opposite called the
bishop usually means High chances for
the draw not here with white king very
active and there goes the bee Pawn now
your spring for your password do not
take it that's why car brings his Bishop
back he does not want to allow connected
past pawns but look at Wesley so inching
in with the queen Nexus King is coming
up to B4 he is kicking Black's pieces
back and I feel like he has great
winning chances uh was going to say yes
Hikaru come on bring the black king
forward bring the black king forward on
the king side but he's just waiting now
but the waiting game is not going to
help too much suddenly you're getting
overwhelmed on this queen side it's
three pieces against two Black's King is
just a innocent bystander here and does
Wesley take another Pawn take it and the
car was shaking his head he hates his
position he hates what he's trying to
defend otherwise he just falls back with
the King now remember there's no
increment here so repetition makes no
sense I'm surprised he didn't pick up
that a second free free porn he's going
backwards that's the wrong direction the
white king is super safe here yes but it
was doing such a good job leading from
the front but the time Wesley so is an
experienced bullet player we know how
good it Karo is Wesley he's no slouch
either so he's using the clock as a
weapon because if they're both spending
a few seconds per turn that's good news
for Wesley because at some point Hikaru
may not be able to find the correct
continuation with just under a minute on
his clock which is where we're heading
yeah that's actually very clever that's
a really relevant Point uh Robert you're
just going to maneuver on the dark
squares you can pretty much pre-move the
next few turns for Wesley and uh only
when you reach that kind of 40 50 move
Mark then you push a point then you
commit and then the counter starts to
Fresh play on that 50 move rule don't
necessarily need to rush to make any
progress and oh wow another offer of a
trade of coins this is confident stuff
from Wesley I would not be 100 confident
this is when uh the winning this this uh
queenless end game but he's asking that
question look how her car is burning
time having to decide Queen trade or no
Queen trade and the state is quite
maintained the clocks are ticking I
wrestlers played amazing chess right now
every move placing a piece on the dark
Square just keeping up the pressure
offering a queen trade at the right time
he does it again hikarus made up his
mind that no matter what he's not going
into an end game here and it's Wesley
slowly and suddenly improving his peace
position the queen has landed on D6 a G4
break in the air so dangerous on both
sides now but F3 that was not timed
correctly by Wesley because look at the
black queen it's ready to jump into the
board if that pawn captures back on B3
so that was an inopportune moment for
Western with this King which is not what
you want you want connected pawns and it
cars immediately going for the attack on
the C2 Pawn he's jumping and you don't
have time to pick up the D5 Pawn the FG
Pawn that he pointed out badly timed is
also hanging yeah suddenly it's turned
around we saw Hikaru do his uh trademark
head Bob there he knows that he's fought
back and now he can just give a couple
of checks where's this white king gonna
hide the black queen can come back where
she came from eye up some of those weak
white pawns on the king side and at
first he activates his King I love to
see it King of the Hill here both Kings
advancing but uh still the clock the
biggest Factor 40 seconds in it now
Wesley retreating he's lost control
suddenly not so easy look how the black
queen is just causing a nuisance from
behind here so many weaknesses in
Wesley's Camp he needs to go for the
flag it may be called dirty it's
whatever go for the time and now he's
doing it but he's giving up some pawns
and his car is really not down the clock
at all it's a pure bullet game at this
point I mean a little over a minute per
side and there are no problems for black
and anymore dermak is asking in the
twitch chat can Wesley simply flag
Hikaru hikaru's position is easier to
play look at this he's just gobbling up
horns black
or dangerous passport Black's H Pawn is
going to start running any moment Wesley
on the defensive on the board and now
not in charge on the clock anymore I
would pick black here I've got to say
and you can see it in his body language
he knows it and Wesley they're shaking
his head he's attacking the bishop
Hikaru gives a check first the king
moves forward that H5 Pawn is going to
be a big distraction and now he says I'm
ready for an end game because he's got a
passer of his own the queen turns a
force there's no way that white can
avoid it without just losing the game on
the spot that's why hikarus saves we're
in the end game white has these outside
pass pawns but look at blacks each Pawn
that one is running up the board very
fast it's helped out it's gonna be
escorted by the black king and the other
pawns this is just easy for a car right
now and he's even ahead on time right he
doesn't have any problems whatsoever
yeah looks like black is completely
winning the race even without Black's
three pawns this is still actually a
draw so uh Hikaru he knows he's got this
in the bag he's smiling he's got a Time
advantage and he clinches his fist
Wesley resigns wow it's uh over Hikaru
Nakamura makes it through to the Grand
Final he will face off against Magnus
Carlsen tomorrow again